Back when Pete was 18 years old, it was the summer before he went away to college. He's home, in the living room with his dad.
彼特18岁那年，是在他离家上大学前的那个夏天。当时他正待在家里，在客厅和父亲在一起。
And he turns to me and he says, Peter, let's go for a drive. And that was not something that he ever said. That's not something that we did.
他转向我对我说：“彼得，我们去兜兜风吧。”那是一句他从来没说过的话。那也不是我们平时会做的事情。
So Pete knows something's up, but he has no idea what. They go outside, get in the Volvo. Pete asks his dad--
所以彼特知道肯定有什么事，但他完全没头绪。他们走到外面，上了沃尔沃。彼特问他父亲——
Shouldn't we get Will, my younger brother? Because he was at home. He was probably 13 or 14. And my dad just shook his head no.
“我们不叫上我弟弟威尔吗？”因为他当时在家。他可能才13或14岁。但我父亲只是摇了摇头。
This drive for Pete, alone with his dad, turned out to be kind of a big moment in his life. Before the drive, if he had to describe his family, it wasn't hard. He could do it in two words.
对彼特来说，这次和他父亲单独的兜风，成了他人生中的一个重大时刻。兜风之前，如果让他描述自己的家庭，并不难。他用两个词就能概括。
Completely mundane. I mean, we lived outside of DC. My parents worked for the government. I mean, they were good parents. They were kind and attentive. And we would have dinner every night. My dad would cook dinner.
“完全平庸。我是说，我们住在华盛顿特区郊外。我父母为政府工作。他们是好父母。他们善良且体贴。我们每天晚上都一起吃晚饭。我父亲会做晚饭。”
Good cook?
“擅长烹饪吗？”
Oh, incredible cook.
“哦，厨艺惊人。”
The way Pete remembers it, he did salmon Sundays, made a great pot roast, had a pizza that he'd make on Fridays. His mom was the one who'd make sure they did their homework and cleaned their rooms. She was direct and more talkative than their dad, who was really quiet.
彼特记忆中的父亲，周日会做三文鱼，做的炖牛肉非常棒，周五还会自制披萨。他的母亲则负责督促他们写作业、打扫房间。她直率且比他们的父亲健谈，父亲平时非常安静。
They were not gregarious. They didn't really have friends. They didn't really have hobbies.
“他们不善交际。他们没什么真正的好友。他们也没什么爱好。”
OK, and so now he is in the car with his dad, just the two of them. Dad pulls out of the driveway.
好吧，现在彼特正和他父亲在车里，就他们俩。父亲把车开出了车道。
So we start driving through our neighborhood, and we get to the stoplight at the end of our neighborhood. And he says to me, Peter, it's time to tell you about the family business, espionage. I mean, my first reaction was, like, what are you doing right now? What kind of joke is this?
“我们开始在社区里开车，开到了社区尽头的红绿灯路口。他对我说：‘彼得，是时候告诉你关于家族生意的事了，是间谍活动。’我的第一反应是：‘你现在在干什么？这算什么玩笑？’”
And then the next thing that he said is, open the glove box. And so I opened the glove box, and inside was a sheet of paper. And he said, take out that sheet of paper. And so I took it out, and I'm scanning the page, and it's his resume from the CIA.
“接下来他说的是：‘打开手套箱。’我打开了手套箱，里面有一张纸。他说：‘把那张纸拿出来。’我把它拿了出来，扫了一眼，那是他在中央情报局（CIA）的简历。”
Did you know he worked for the CIA?
“你知道他在中情局工作吗？”
No.
“不知道。”
Where did you think he worked?
“你以为他在哪儿工作？”
Well, he said he worked at the State Department.
“嗯，他说他在国务院工作。”
But now, on this sheet of paper, it listed all the different countries that Pete had lived with his parents-- Germany and the Netherlands and Jamaica, countries where Pete had always thought that his dad was going off to an embassy or consulate every day to work for the State Department.
但现在，那张纸上列出了彼特曾随父母居住过的所有国家——德国、荷兰和牙买加，彼特一直以为父亲每天去大使馆或领事馆工作是为了国务院。
And I'm seeing, like, counterintelligence, and counterinsurgency, and deputy chief, chief of station, case officer. I didn't know what to ask next. And I honestly don't know that we talked very much at all. So we actually drove in a big loop and drove back down into the driveway. And I was like, oh, wait, does Mom know about this? And my dad goes, oh, um, she works there, too.
“我看到上面写着：反间谍、反叛乱、副站长、站长、案件官员。我不知道接下来该问什么。老实说，我不知道我们当时到底谈了多少。我们实际上绕了一大圈，又开回了车道。我说：‘等等，妈妈知道这事吗？’我父亲说：‘哦，嗯，她也在那儿工作。’”
This stunned him. His dad, he could kind of see. His dad was quiet, like somebody who keeps keep secrets.
这让他惊呆了。对他父亲，他还能理解。父亲沉默寡言，看起来就是个守得住秘密的人。
But with my mom, it was completely out of-- it was just a complete surprise because of how she was.
“但对我母亲，这完全出乎意料，因为她平时的样子。”
What do you mean?
“什么意思？”
She just was somebody who-- it just seemed like you were getting exactly what you got. She just didn't really seem like somebody who could deceive. But I guess she was.
“她就是那种……看起来是什么样就是什么样的人。她看起来真不像个会撒谎的人。但我猜她是。”
And were they the kind of CIA employees who analyze data and sit at a desk, work a desk? Or were they out in the field, spying, pretending to be people who they aren't, carrying a gun? Were that kind of CIA?
“他们是那种分析数据、坐在办公室里工作的CIA员工吗？还是他们在外勤一线，搞间谍活动、伪装身份、带着枪？是那种CIA吗？”
They were out in the field. Yeah, they were undercover. They had passports with other names. And the way it was described to me is that they were not spies. They were recruiting spies from other countries. And in doing so, they were pretending to be people who they were not.
“他们在前线。是的，他们是卧底。他们持有其他名字的护照。对我描述的情况是，他们不是间谍。他们是招募外国间谍的。在做这些事时，他们伪装成别人。”
Pete says before this, he just hadn't really thought much about his parents and their lives and their jobs. He was a kid. He once asked his mom, what do you actually do at your government job all day long?
彼特说在此之前，他真的没怎么考虑过父母的生活和工作。他当时还是个孩子。他曾问过母亲：“你在政府工作，整天到底在做什么？”
And I think my mom said something like, oh, it's just meetings and memos. And I was like, yeah, I figured. Just boring stuff.
“我想我母亲当时大概说了些‘哦，就是开会和写备忘录’之类的话。我就说：‘嗯，我想也是。都是些枯燥的事情。’”
Yeah. Which, I have to say, I bet there were meetings and memos, so it's like, that isn't 100% lie. It's just leaving some stuff out.
“是的。我敢说他们确实有开会和写备忘录，所以那也不完全是谎话。只是省略了一些内容。”
Yeah. No, definitely using boringness as a kind of deception.
“是的。确实是在用枯燥感作为一种伪装。”
In retrospect, Pete says, there were clues that he could have maybe picked up on. His mom spoke several languages. The family lived most of his life in other countries. His dad owned a 9 millimeter pistol and was always up at 4:00 in the morning to go running on a track. It was the fact that his parents didn't have friends and never had anybody over to the house-- which, of course, doesn't mean that you're a spy, but still.
回想起来，彼特说，有些线索他本可以察觉到。他母亲会说多种语言。他们家大部分时间都生活在国外。他父亲有一把9毫米手枪，每天凌晨4点起床去田径场跑步。还有一个事实是，他父母没有朋友，也从不邀请任何人到家里来——当然，这并不意味着你就是间谍，但还是很有疑点。
Yeah, it actually wasn't until a lot later that I realized that a lot of adults do have friends and still hang out. And there were things like when I would go to the mall with my mom, she always made sure we knew a code word. And she would say like, OK, so if Mommy's ever not here, and somebody comes to pick you up, make sure they know the code word. And the code word was always "Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles."
“是的，其实直到很久以后我才意识到，很多成年人确实有朋友，而且会经常聚会。还有一些事情，比如我和我妈去商场时，她总是确保我们知道一个暗号。她会说：‘好的，如果妈妈不在了，有人来接你，一定要确认他们知道暗号。’暗号一直是‘忍者神龟’。”
Wait, anytime you would go to the mall, your mom would remind you of this?
“等等，每次你们去商场，你妈都会提醒你这个？”
Yeah, we'd be in the back seat, and she'd be like, OK, boys, what's the code word? And we'd say, Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
“是的，我们在后座，她会说：‘好的，孩子们，暗号是什么？’我们就说：‘忍者神龟’。”
At the time, he says, he chalked it up to 1990s stranger danger stuff, but he learned that other parents do not do this. And he told me there was one more clue about his parents' jobs, a clue was sitting right there during the years they moved back to Virginia.
他说，当时他把这归结为20世纪90年代针对陌生人的警惕教育，但后来他才知道，其他父母并不这样做。他还告诉我关于父母工作的另一个线索，这个线索在他们搬回弗吉尼亚州的那些年里一直就在那儿。
Maybe the biggest clue of all is that we lived right across the street from the CIA headquarters.
“也许最大的线索就是，我们住的地方正对着中情局总部。”
Wait, what?
“等等，什么？”
Yeah. [LAUGHS] That makes a lot of sense because my dad was super pragmatic, and he hated traffic.
“是的。[笑声] 这说得通，因为我父亲非常务实，而且他讨厌交通拥堵。”
To be clear, they weren't literally across the street, but in a neighborhood right across the street. Door to door, less than five minutes. Pete's parents are both dead now. They both retired from the CIA after long careers-- which is why it's OK to talk about it here on the radio, by the way. But when Pete learned about this, it really did make their lives seem so much more impressive.
需要明确的是，他们不是真的隔着马路，而是在隔着马路的社区里。从门口出发，不到五分钟。彼特的父母现在都去世了。他们退休前都在中情局工作了很长时间——顺便说一下，这就是为什么现在在电台里讲出来没问题。但当彼特得知这些时，这确实让他们的生活看起来令人印象深刻得多。
Like, they met in the CIA, fell in love in the CIA. They were globetrotting and bringing their kids around and doing God knows what.
比如，他们在CIA相识，在CIA相爱。他们周游世界，带着孩子到处走，还做了天知道什么事。
I'm not exactly sure how to ask this question, so I'm just going to ask this straight out. Like, the one thing that I know about spies from movies is that they're all really, really hot. Were your parents really hot?
“我不确定该怎么问这个问题，所以我直接问了。关于间谍，我从电影里知道的一件事就是他们都特别特别性感。你父母很性感吗？”
[CHUCKLING] I mean, yeah, they were hot. Yeah, they were hot. They were very attractive people. My mom was-- I have these old pictures of her, and she's just beautiful.
[轻笑] “我是说，是的，他们很性感。是的，他们很性感。他们是非常有魅力的人。我妈——我有她的旧照片，她简直美极了。”
And your dad?
“那你父亲呢？”
Yeah, handsome guy.
“是的，很帅。”
There's this concept that originally was in video games, and then it spread to TV shows and to social media, where-- OK, say, in a video game, there's the universe that everything takes place in, right? And then at some point, the game creators do a new lore drop, where they give backstory or reveal important details that suddenly make everything seem different and richer and more complicated, shed a whole new light.
有一个概念最初出现在电子游戏中，后来传播到电视剧和社交媒体上，就是——好吧，比如说，在电子游戏中，有一个故事发生的宇宙，对吧？然后，在某个时刻，游戏创作者发布了新的“传说（lore drop）”，他们给出背景故事或揭示重要细节，突然让一切看起来都不一样了，更丰富、更复杂，呈现出一个全新的视角。
Pete had that. He had a new lore drop in his actual life. He thought his parents were one thing, then learned backstory that changed his whole picture of them. So what's that like to live through in real life?
彼特就经历了这一点。他在现实生活中经历了一次新的“传说发布”。他以为父母是那样的人，后来得知了改变他对他们所有印象的背景故事。那么在现实生活中经历这种感觉是什么样的？
Yeah. I mean, I think at first, it was a shock, the fact that they were able to deceive me for my whole life. And that is just weird. It did make me look at them differently. Like, wow, the rug just got pulled from under me. Everything I know is a lie. But then when that wears off, it's kind of like, well, it's still just Mom and Dad.
“是的。我是说，起初这是一种冲击，他们能欺骗我一辈子的事实。这真的很奇怪。它确实让我以不同的眼光看待他们。就像：哇，地毯刚从我脚下抽走了。我所知道的一切都是谎言。但当那种感觉消退后，又会觉得：嗯，他们依然只是我的爸爸妈妈。”
Pete says everybody goes through the thing when they grow up, where they learn to see their parents not just as the boring human furniture around the house of their childhood. And for most of us, the new information that we absorb about our parents happens over years. The new lore drop version that Pete got was just kind of the accelerated program.
彼特说，每个人在长大时都会经历这样一个过程，学会不再把父母仅仅看作童年家里那些乏味的人类家具。对于我们大多数人来说，关于父母的新信息是多年来逐渐吸收的。彼特得到的那个“新传说发布”版本，简直就是加速版。
Yeah, I got it all in one drive.
“是的，我全是在那次兜风中得知的。”
Today on our show, we have other human beings who are not video game characters, and they're not fictional people on long-running television series, who get hit with all new information about their own lives, backstories that rewrite everything, new lore drops in real life. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Today on the show, I will still be playing the part that I always play here. And I have not learned that I am a princess from Genovia, and my grandmother is actually Julie Andrews. I am still Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，还有其他不是游戏角色、也不是虚构电视连续剧人物的真实人类，他们被关于自己生活的新信息击中，改写了一切的背景故事，现实生活中的新传说。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》。今天在节目中，我将继续扮演我在这里一直扮演的角色。我并没有发现自己是来自吉诺维亚的公主，我的祖母也不是朱莉·安德鲁斯。我依然是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, Save the Drama for Your Grandmama. Sometimes, a lore drop happens when you least expect it, like in this next story. Aviva DeKornfeld explains.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，把戏剧留给你的祖母。有时，传说会在你最意想不到的时候出现，就像接下来的这个故事一样。Aviva DeKornfeld为你讲述。
When I first met Jake, it was obvious. This is a guy who was hardwired to try and connect with people. He's like this friendly bulldozer, Kool-Aid Man-ing his way into emotional intimacy. And Jake's always been this way, in part, perhaps, because he grew up surrounded by people. He comes from this big Irish Catholic family in Rhode Island, and he had a sort of sitcom upbringing. His aunts and uncles and cousins all lived close by. One grandma lived literally next door. The other set of grandparents lived a 15-minute walk from his house, and Jake saw them every day. It was the best.
当我第一次见到杰克时，显而易见，这是一个天生就渴望与人建立联系的人。他就像一台友好的推土机，用“酷爱饮料人（Kool-Aid Man）”的方式横冲直撞进别人的情感世界。杰克一直都是这样，部分原因可能是因为他成长在人群中。他来自罗德岛一个庞大的爱尔兰天主教家庭，有着典型的电视情景喜剧式的成长环境。他的阿姨、叔叔和表亲们都住在附近。一位祖母简直就住在隔壁。另一对祖父母住在离他家步行15分钟的地方，杰克每天都见到他们。那感觉太棒了。
And then, when he was seven years old, his family moved to Vermont, away from his extended family. And he hated it, really missed them. And this missing only intensified when his grandma back in Rhode Island was diagnosed with breast cancer. To little Jake, it was obvious what to do.
然后，在他七岁那年，他全家搬到了佛蒙特州，远离了他的大家庭。他讨厌那里，真的很想念他们。当他在罗德岛的祖母被诊断出患有乳腺癌时，这种思念变得更加强烈。对于小杰克来说，该做什么显而易见。
I just started calling her all the time, and I think because I just wanted to keep talking to her because I was so afraid she was going to die.
“我开始不停地给她打电话，我想是因为我只想和她说话，因为我太害怕她会死掉。”
Oh, my God. It's so sweet.
“噢，天哪。太甜了。”
I know. [LAUGHS] And it's funny to think back on because it was so purely intentioned, but it's also so-- the motives of it are so transparent that it must have just been a reminder to my grandmother every day, like, this kid thinks you're going to die because you might. You know what I mean?
“我知道。[笑声] 回想起来很有趣，因为初衷非常纯粹，但也非常……这些动机太透明了，以至于这每天肯定都在提醒我的祖母：这个孩子觉得你会死，因为你确实可能死。你明白我的意思吗？”
Yeah.
“明白。”
It was kind of like no--
“感觉就像不——”
She was like, OK, relax.
“她当时就像是：好了，放松点。”
No, 'cause she was like, I was trying to have one day of fucking peace. And I'm like, hi, Grandma, can I talk to you again before you die?
“不，因为她是那种：我只想哪怕有一天该死的清静。而我却在说：嘿，祖母，我能在你死前再跟你聊聊吗？”
I kind of have this memory of the calls kind of running out of steam a little bit because I was calling every single day, and I was like eight or nine. And so it's like, what? What do you have to talk about, you know? And so I think I had introduced her to Harry Potter, just as I had started reading it. And I think we were then-- we would read them at the same time, and we would read a chapter a night, talk on the phone the next day. We would discuss the chapter, sort of like book club with my grandma.
“我记得那种通话渐渐有点没劲了，因为我每天都打，而且我当时只有八九岁。所以就是，什么？你有什么可说的，你知道吗？所以我认为我把《哈利·波特》介绍给了她，正是我刚开始读的时候。我想我们当时就是——我们会同时读，一晚读一章，第二天在电话里聊。我们会讨论那一章，就像我和祖母的读书俱乐部。”
I remember-- my mom always jokes one of the most upset times she ever saw me was I caught that my grandma had read ahead. Because she accidentally said something on one of the calls that hadn't happened yet. And I was like, what are you talking about? And she was like, well, doesn't it? And I was like, you read ahead. And she had read the whole book because she couldn't put it down because she loved it.
“我记得——我妈妈总是开玩笑说，她见过的我最崩溃的一次，是我发现祖母提前读了。因为她在一次通话中无意中说了一些还没发生的事。我说：‘你在说什么？’她说：‘嗯，难道不是这样吗？’我说：‘你提前读了！’她把整本书都读完了，因为她放不下，她太喜欢了。”
Right.
“没错。”
But I was like, never do that again. Swear to me that you'll never-- because I loved that I had that experience with her.
“但我说：‘永远不要再那样做了。向我发誓你永远不会……’因为我喜欢和她一起经历那种体验。”
This Harry Potter book club evolved into talking about other books, books they were reading separately. The way it worked, they would each read their own book, and then they'd hop on the phone and summarize it for the other person, chapter by chapter.
这个《哈利·波特》读书俱乐部演变成了讨论其他书，他们各自独立阅读的书。运作方式是，他们各读各的，然后打个电话，逐章为对方总结。
It was part of my nightly ritual. I feel like it was come home, do homework, maybe have dinner, then call Grandma, and recap the book. Because I always loved recapping my book to her. I loved having someone to tell this story to so that it was like, I loved being able to retell it. I want to tell her this story in the way it made me feel. I want to make sure I hide this suspense. I want to-- if there was a surprise in the book, I wanted to make sure I tell her the story of the book in a way that keeps the surprise, so that she's as surprised when I tell her as I was when I read it. And then I'd be like, OK, what about your books? And she would tell me.
“那是我每晚仪式的一部分。感觉就像是回家，做作业，吃晚饭，然后给祖母打电话，重述书里的内容。因为我一直很喜欢把书的内容讲给她听。我喜欢有一个人可以倾诉这个故事，就像是，我喜欢重述它的能力。我想以让我感到那种方式告诉她这个故事。我想确保我隐藏了悬念。我想——如果书里有惊喜，我想确保我以一种保持惊喜的方式讲述故事，这样她听我讲的时候和我读的时候一样惊讶。然后我会说：‘好的，你的书怎么样？’她会告诉我。”
And I remember kind of clocking pretty early on that she definitely didn't have that same flair for-- she just didn't-- she would be like, oh, and then, yeah, they're starting to fall in love. And I'd be like, well, how do they fall in love? Why do they like each other? I felt very connected to her through the books and through the storytelling.
“我记得很早就注意到，她绝对没有那种天赋——她只是不……她会说：‘哦，然后，是的，他们开始坠入爱河了。’我会说：‘好吧，他们是怎么坠入爱河的？为什么他们喜欢对方？’我感到通过书籍和讲故事与她建立了紧密的联系。”
Because I think my grandma was not-- she wasn't particularly forthcoming about herself. She wasn't someone who would come home and drop her bag and like, God, I gotta tell you about my day. That was not her. And this was the first time that I felt like I was having a conversation with an adult who was talking to me about stuff going on in their own life, even if it was just the book they were reading.
“因为我觉得我的祖母不是那种——她对自己的事情不怎么坦诚。她不是那种回家放下包就说：‘天哪，我得告诉你我的一天。’她不是那种人。这是我第一次觉得我是在和一个成年人交谈，她跟我聊着她自己生活里的事情，即使只是她正在读的书。”
Jake's grandma worked at Filene's, in the shoe department. She was a real coupon hound, loved a sale. She was nice, but not exactly sweet in a grandmotherly kind of way. She was often way too honest. Like, if you said you weren't feeling good about yourself because your clothes didn't fit right, she would offer, well, you gained weight.
杰克的祖母在Filene's百货公司的鞋类部门工作。她是个真正的优惠券搜集狂，喜欢打折。她人很好，但不是那种祖母般的甜美。她经常太诚实了。比如说，如果你说因为衣服不合身而对自己感觉不好，她会直言不讳地说：“好吧，你长胖了。”
She liked reading all kinds of books, but she especially loved thrillers. Jake remembers one of her books in particular, Smoke and Mirrors, about a librarian whose half-sister was murdered. The librarian tries to figure out who murdered her half-sister with the help of a guy who knew her. It was suspenseful. His grandma loved a mystery.
她喜欢读各种书，但特别喜欢惊悚小说。杰克记得她的一本书《烟雾与镜子》（Smoke and Mirrors），关于一个异母妹妹被谋杀的图书管理员。图书管理员在认识死者的一个男人的帮助下，试图查出是谁谋杀了她妹妹。情节很悬疑。他祖母热爱悬疑。
The two kept this book club going for years. Jake would pace back and forth in the hall between the dining room and living room in his house in Vermont, phone tucked under his ear, while his grandma sat nestled in her favorite armchair back in Rhode Island. The calls were long, sometimes lasting hours.
两人就这样把读书俱乐部维持了好几年。杰克在佛蒙特州的家中在餐厅和客厅之间的走廊里来回踱步，电话夹在耳边，而他的祖母在罗德岛蜷缩在她最喜欢的扶手椅里。通话很长，有时持续几个小时。
Jake says his summaries were, unsurprisingly, pretty exhaustive. He didn't want to leave a single detail out, until, when he was 12 or so, he stopped being completely honest with his grandma about what he was reading because he started feeling like there was something off about the books he liked. He worried they were too girly.
杰克说他的总结不出意料地非常详尽。他不想漏掉任何一个细节，直到他12岁左右，他开始不再对祖母完全诚实地讲述他在读什么，因为他开始觉得他喜欢的书有点不对劲。他担心它们太“娘”了。
The ones where I was like, oh, these were the ones that really caused a crisis for me, there was this series of books called Twitches, which were about twin witches. [LAUGHS] And they were like-- the covers were like those old-school, early 2000s photoshoots where they would do stock image photoshoots. It wasn't like an illustration. It was like a photoshoot of two teenage girls.
“那些我当时觉得：哦，这些书真的让我产生了危机感，有一系列书叫《双子巫师》（Twitches），是关于一对双子巫师的。[笑声] 封面就像那种老派、2000年初的照片拍摄，库存图片摄影。不是插画，而是两个十几岁女孩的照片。”
Like Olson twins style.
“像奥尔森双胞胎那种风格？”
Totally.
“完全是。”
Matching outfits.
“搭配的衣服。”
Exactly. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was about these two girls who found out that they were adopted and that they were twins. They're also witches. When they meet, they develop magical powers. And I was like, well, I literally have to read these. But I don't want to tell my grandma that I'm reading a book about two teenage girls that have magical powers and like boys. And also, I don't want to carry this book around at school. And so I think that's when I started editing a little bit and--
“没错。是的，是的，是的。讲的是两个女孩发现自己被收养，而且是一对双胞胎。她们还是巫师。当她们见面时，她们发展出了魔法能力。我想，我简直必须读这些。但我不想告诉祖母我在读一本关于两个有魔法能力、还喜欢男孩的十几岁女孩的书。而且我也不想在学校里带着这本书。所以我认为那时我开始做了一些编辑……”
And why didn't you want your grandma to know you were reading those books?
“为什么你不想让你的祖母知道你在读那些书？”
Because I think I knew it was speaking to something. I think I was also probably starting to realize-- because I also was a pretty effeminate child. So at this point, I was already getting called gay. So I think this was all kind of interwoven.
“因为我想我知道那暗示着什么。我想我也可能开始意识到——因为我当时也是个挺女性化的孩子。所以到这个时候，我已经开始被骂‘基佬’了。所以我认为这一切都有点交织在一起。”
And so do you remember intentionally deciding to start changing details?
“那你还记得故意决定开始改变细节吗？”
I remember in Twitches, I think I changed their gender. I think I made them both boys. I think I changed their powers. I think I said that one could move things with their mind and that one was strong.
“我记得在《双子巫师》里，我想我改变了她们的性别。我想我把她们都改成了男孩。我想我改变了她们的能力。我想我说一个可以用大脑移动物体，另一个力大无穷。”
And the details you were changing, it was to make it align with what you thought a straight boy would be reading?
“你改变的细节，是为了让它符合你认为一个直男会读的东西吗？”
I guess so. I was like, I'll change these details because they don't affect the plot. And so I was like, I'm not going to change the plot. I'm just going to change the details around it to make it a little bit more masc. So it's going to be-- instead of being able to passively stop it through clairvoyance and telepathy, it's like, they use their physical powers of telekinesis and strength.
“我想是吧。我想：我会改变这些细节，因为它们不影响情节。所以我说：我不会改变情节。我只会改变周围的细节，让它变得更‘直男’一点。所以它会是——与其通过预知和心灵感应被动地阻止它，不如说，他们利用心灵遥感和力量的物理能力。”
And do you think you were convincing? Do you think that she thought that you were straight at the time?
“你觉得你成功了吗？你觉得那时她认为你是直的吗？”
No. I don't think that anyone ever thought I was straight.
“没有。我不认为有人曾经认为我是直的。”
Really?
“真的吗？”
No, I don't think so.
“不，我不这么认为。”
It's really sweet and really sad to imagine you putting on this disguise by changing the details for your grandma. It's like you're wearing a fake mustache, but it's actually askew, and you have no idea. And everyone's like, that's not a real mustache.
“想象你为了祖母通过改变细节来伪装自己，这既可爱又悲伤。就像你戴着假胡子，但它其实是歪的，而你毫无察觉。每个人都在想：那不是真正的胡子。”
Yeah, 100%. And as though like if I'd been sitting here talking to you for an hour and a half, and then just suddenly put the mustache on and expect you to think it was real. You've been talking--
“是的，百分之百。就像如果我在这儿跟你聊了一个半小时，然后突然戴上胡子，还指望你觉得它是真的。”
Right.
“没错。”
--to me without a mustache this whole time. And I also think this kind of led to the end of the book club a little bit, was when I started to be like, I don't want to read these books and have to tell my grandma. But you know what I mean?
“这一直都没戴胡子。而且我也认为这在一定程度上导致了读书俱乐部的结束，那就是当我开始想：我不想读这些书然后还得告诉我的祖母。但你懂我的意思吗？”
Yeah.
“懂。”
Also, she beat the cancer. Congratulations. So I was less scared about her dying.
“另外，她战胜了癌症。恭喜她。所以我对她去世的恐惧减少了。”
Oh, so you were like, OK, it's not an emergency.
“噢，所以你觉得：好吧，这不再是紧急情况了。”
I think kind of. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
“我想有点儿。是的，是的，是的。”
It took Jake a few more years to formally come out to his family. He was 16. And he told me, he thinks he remembers his grandma mentioning his coming out once and saying that she loved him. But it was such a non-issue that he can't even really remember specifics. Jake's sexuality, that is not the lore drop in this story. There was one, but it came years later, when Jake was in his 30s. By then, his grandma had developed dementia and then got really sick. Jake made a point to visit her every month or two. And then one day--
杰克又过了几年才正式向家人出柜。他当时16岁。他告诉我，他想他记得祖母在他出柜时提过一次，说她爱他。但这已经不是什么大问题了，他甚至记不清具体细节。杰克的性取向，并不是这个故事里的“传说发布”。那个东西后来才出现，当杰克30多岁的时候。那时，他的祖母患上了痴呆症，然后病得很重。杰克坚持每月或两个月探望她一次。然后有一天——
I was visiting my grandma, and she was in in-home hospice. And it was kind of sad. And she was on the first floor in the living room. And then I went up to my mom's old bedroom. And my mom's bedroom, there's this radiator that always was just covered in my grandma's books. And I remember being in-- I think I probably went up to the room to take a breather or something. And I remember seeing the books on the windowsill and on the radiator.
“我当时在探望我的祖母，她在接受居家临终关怀。那挺让人难过的。她在楼下的客厅里。然后我去了我妈妈以前的卧室。在妈妈的卧室里，有一个暖气片，上面总是摆满了祖母的书。我记得当时在——我想我大概是上楼去透透气什么的。我记得看到书架上和暖气片上的书。”
He saw titles he remembered from when he was a kid, the book she'd recapped for him.
他看到了他小时候记得的书名，那些她曾经给他重述过的书。
And I remember I picked up one of the books and thumbed through it and found a sex scene. And I was like, was she reading-- they're romance novels. These were sexy books. And so I picked them up, and I started flipping through them. And I just remember it being graphic in the way that it described genitals. It wasn't just like, and then we went to the bedroom. It was like, [BLEEP]. You know what I mean? It was like that. And I was like, oh, oh, OK. I was like, are those all smut?
“我记得我拿起其中一本书，翻了翻，发现了一个性爱场景。我当时想：她在读……那是浪漫小说。这些是色情书籍。所以我拿起它们，开始翻阅。我只记得它在描述生殖器方面很直白。不仅仅是‘然后我们进了卧室’。而是那种，[消音]。你懂我的意思吗？就是那样。我说：‘噢，噢，好吧。’我想：‘这些全是色情读物吗？’”
Yes, Jake's grandma was an avid reader of smut. Jake sat there laughing out loud to himself as he started googling his grandma's favorite authors-- Jayne Ann Krentz, who wrote the book Grand Passion, in which protagonist Max Fortune heads to a B&B in search of his hidden inheritance, only to find himself irresistibly compelled by the attractive innkeeper, Cleopatra.
是的，杰克的祖母是一个热衷于色情读物的读者。杰克坐在那里，一边自嘲地大笑，一边开始用谷歌搜索他祖母最喜欢的作者——Jayne Ann Krentz，她写了《Grand Passion》，书中主角Max Fortune为了寻找隐藏的遗产前往一家民宿，却发现自己被迷人的旅店老板Cleopatra深深吸引。
JD Robb-- she wrote the book Naked in Death, where a woman somehow works through her past trauma by sleeping with a hot and mysterious Irish businessman. And another one from Jayne Ann Krentz that Jake remembered his grandma recapping to him, Smoke and Mirrors, the one about the librarian traveling around trying to solve her half-sister's murder with the help of a guy she meets along the way. That was the way Jake remembered it, anyway. But now, reading the book--
JD Robb——她写了《Naked in Death》，书中一个女人通过与一个性感神秘的爱尔兰商人睡觉，以某种方式克服了她过去的创伤。还有另一本Jayne Ann Krentz的书，杰克记得他祖母给他重述过，《烟雾与镜子》，那个关于图书管理员四处奔波，在旅途中遇到一个男人的帮助下试图破获她妹妹谋杀案的故事。反正杰克记忆中是这样。但现在，重读这本书——
The whole book is just her wanting to have sex with this man. That's the entire book. The murder is almost never mentioned. They're just walking around this town, trying to find out if the murder-- the entire time, she's just like, this man is so hot. She literally had to make up so much plot. This is so central to the plot. I remember thinking, like, damn, Grandma doesn't give that much of a shit about the narrative. And I'm like, no, Grandma was making up a narrative because half of the plot was about these people having sex. So you want me to read this passage?
“整本书全是她想和这个男人发生关系。情节几乎全在这。谋杀案几乎从未被提及。他们只是在镇上走来走去，试图找出谋杀案——全程她都在说：‘这个男人太性感了。’她简直不得不编造了那么多情节。这对于情节太关键了。我记得当时想：该死，祖母对叙事根本不在乎。我想：不，祖母是在编造一个叙事，因为情节的一半都是关于这些人发生关系。你想让我读这段吗？”
Yeah.
“想。”
OK. In this part of the book, they just tried to break into a house to look for clues. And an unseen person chased them out of the house, and they had to run away. And now, they're back at his place, and they're safe. OK.
“好的。书的这一部分，他们刚试图闯进一所房子找线索。一个看不见的人把他们从屋里追了出来，他们不得不逃跑。现在，他们回到他的住处，安全了。好了。”
"Thomas shrugged out of his jacket and came to stand behind her. Their eyes met in the mirror. Unlike her, he looked terrific, she thought, hard, tough, and totally in control. She had to fight an irresistible urge to turn and put her head into his chest. His hands closed over her shoulders. 'Take it easy. You're just feeling the aftershock of the adrenaline. It'll fade.' 'I know.'
“Thomas甩掉夹克，站在她身后。他们的目光在镜子里相遇。和她不同，她想，他看起来棒极了，强硬、顽强，完全掌控一切。她不得不抑制住一种不可抗拒的冲动，想转身把头靠在他的胸口。他的双手握住她的肩膀：‘放轻松。你只是在经历肾上腺素的余波。它会消失的。’‘我知道。’”
The weight of his hands was not having the calming, soothing effect he probably intended. She suddenly wanted to do a lot more than just put her head down on his shoulder. She looked at his mouth in the mirror and wondered what would it be like to kiss him, wondered how his mouth would feel on other parts of her body." [LAUGHS]
“他双手的重量并没有产生他可能打算的那种平静、舒缓的效果。她突然想要做的不仅仅是把头靠在他的肩上。她在镜子里看着他的嘴，想知道吻他会是什么感觉，想知道他的嘴在她身体其他部位的感觉会是什么样。”[笑声]
Let's stop there, because we can't conjure an image on the radio.
“咱们就在这儿停吧，因为我们没法在电台里展现画面。”
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
You guys were doing the same thing.
“你们当时在做同样的事情。”
We were doing the same thing.
“我们确实在做同样的事情。”
What went through your head when you realized that?
“当你意识到这一点时，你的脑子里想的是什么？”
It really tickled me. I was like-- because I remembered that feeling of being so afraid towards the end of the time when we were calling each other, that I would out myself, or just feeling-- once I became a sexual person myself or pubescent myself, those conversations about those books being like, ah! Don't see me!
“这真的挠到了我的痒处。我当时是——因为我记得在我们的通话快结束时，那种极度害怕我会出柜，或者一旦我自己也进入青春期，成为了一个有性意识的人，那些关于那些书的谈话，就像：‘啊！别看我！’”
Yeah.
“是的。”
And realizing she probably felt a version of that the whole time.
“并意识到她可能一直都有那种感觉。”
Totally.
“完全正确。”
Or it was just having to constantly think about, OK, don't talk about when they had sex in the kitchen. But what happened to the plotline? I don't know. It makes me feel closer to her that we were doing this song and dance.
“或者她只是不得不不断地思考：好的，别谈论他们在厨房里发生关系的时候。但情节线发生了什么？我不知道。这让我觉得和她更亲近了，因为我们当时在演这出戏。”
I love the idea that you and your grandma were lying to one another three times a week in the name of bonding.
“我喜欢这种想法：你和你的祖母为了保持亲密，一周三次互相撒谎。”
[LAUGHS] Exactly. It's like, "lie" almost feels like too harsh of a word. Do you know what I mean?
[笑声] “没错。就像‘谎言’这个词听起来太刺耳了。你懂我的意思吗？”
Yeah.
“懂。”
It's just like two people translating what's going on in their lives for the other person, you know?
“这只是两个人为了对方而翻译他们生活中发生的事情，你知道吗？”
Right, it's a version of what we all do all the time.
“没错，这是我们所有人一直在做的事情的一种版本。”
100%, you know? When we talk to our parents about our relationship, you might not be like, well, I think I might break up with him because the sex is not great. Like, you might-- ah, I'm just not feeling it. You know what I mean? We do these edits all the time, you know?
“百分之百，你知道吗？当我们和父母聊我们的关系时，你可能不会说：‘嗯，我想我可能会和他分手，因为性生活不太好。’你可能只会说：‘唉，我就是没感觉。’你懂我的意思吗？我们一直在做这些编辑。”
Yeah, like, yeah, we were fighting, and then we made up.
“是的，比如，是的，我们吵架了，然后我们和好了。”
Yeah. [LAUGHS] Exactly.
“是的。[笑声] 没错。”
Jake's grandma died this past June. She was 84. Jake and his grandma and their book club, it was never really about the books, obviously. The point was to spend time with one another, to feel close. And it worked. It worked so well that Jake still gets to spend time with her, even now, even in some very unexpected moments.
杰克的祖母于去年六月去世。享年84岁。杰克和他的祖母以及他们的读书俱乐部，显然从没真正关乎过书。重点是花时间在一起，感受亲密。而且它奏效了。效果太好了，以至于杰克即使现在，甚至在某些非常意想不到的时刻，依然能和她在一起。
I've been watching Heated Rivalry, which is this HBO Max show that's based on a romance novel, but it's a gay romance novel. It's about hockey players. And I'm loving it. It's my favorite show right now. And I'm kind of laughing to myself as I watch it because I'm like, I come from a line of people who enjoy this. This is like-- you know? It's like--
“我一直在看《Heated Rivalry》，那是HBO Max的一部基于浪漫小说的剧，但它是同性浪漫小说。是关于曲棍球运动员的。我很喜欢。它是我现在最喜欢的剧。我看的时候有点自嘲，因为我想：我来自一个享受这一点的家庭。这就像是……你知道吗？”
I'm continuing my family tradition.
“我在延续我的家庭传统。”
Not that I'm think-- let's be clear to the listener. I'm not thinking about my grandma, necessarily, when I'm watching a lot of those scenes. But when I think about it now, I'm like, there is something kind of nice about that, I guess. I found my version of it that I enjoy. There was a period of time in my life where I was terrified of my grandma knowing I was gay, and now I'm watching gay smut on HBO. And I'm like, the gene that makes me like this comes from her.
“不是说我在想……咱们跟听众说清楚。当我在看很多那些场景时，我不一定是在想我的祖母。但现在想起来，我想：那确实有一种挺不错的感觉，我想。我找到了我享受的版本。在我生命中有一段时间，我非常害怕祖母知道我是同性恋，而现在我在HBO上看同性色情作品。我心想：让我喜欢这一点的基因来自她。”
Sometimes the new lore drop isn't some big revelation. Sometimes it's just a funny little detail. You get to enjoy it and carry on with your day.
有时新的传说发布不是什么大启示。有时它只是一个小小的、有趣的细节。你可以享受它，然后继续你的生活。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show. Jake is a comedian. He told a version of this story on stage, which is where we first heard about it. His work and his tour dates are on Instagram, @jakewcornell. Coming up, one more reason to hate Mark Zuckerberg. This one, I bet you did not see coming. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
Aviva DeKornfeld是我们节目的制作人之一。杰克是一位喜剧演员。他在舞台上讲过这个故事的一个版本，这就是我们最初听到它的地方。他的作品和巡演日期都在Instagram上，@jakewcornell。接下来，多一个讨厌马克·扎克伯格的理由。这个，我打赌你绝对没猜到。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台回来，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, new lore drop-- stories of people discovering information about their own lives that they did not know, information that makes them see things very differently. OK, so just a quick reminder as the show continues, if we get separated and you can't find me, and somebody comes to get you, let's just review, what's the code word?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，新的传说发布——人们发现关于自己生活的新信息，这些信息让他们看待事情的方式变得完全不同。好了，就在节目继续时快速提醒一下，如果我们走散了，你找不到我，有人来接你，咱们来复习一下，暗号是什么？
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
“忍者神龟。”
That's right. Don't forget it. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Bully Pulpit. So reporter Ben Austen had a kind of lore drop happen to him recently. And it was not the clarifying kind of lore drop where everything suddenly makes sense, the world seems clearer. It was kind of the opposite.
“没错。别忘了。我们进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，恃强凌弱的讲坛。记者Ben Austen最近也经历了一次传说发布。那不是那种让一切突然变得明朗、世界看起来更清晰的传说。它正好相反。
Ben's whole thing started over Facebook. Ben is one of those people who hates Facebook. He hates, but also keeps looking at. Maybe he's not the only person who ever does that. Ben had this rule. He would accept friend requests, but he'd never make them. And then one day, he sees a post that his sixth grade teacher had died. This was a teacher he loved and everybody loved, and all of his old classmates were sharing memories.
Ben的整个事情是从Facebook上开始的。Ben是那种讨厌Facebook的人。他讨厌它，但又忍不住一直看。也许他不是唯一一个这样做的人。Ben有个原则。他会接受好友请求，但从不主动发起。有一天，他看到一个帖子，说他六年级的老师去世了。这是一位他爱戴、大家也都爱戴的老师，他所有的老同学都在分享回忆。
I was sitting there, and I was like, man, these are my friends that I grew up with. And so I started friending them. I broke my rule. And there was this kid Chaka that I hung out with, and this girl Alana and Malcolm Speller. I just started friending all of them. And then there was this one other kid. His name was Eddie. And I paused.
“我就坐在那儿，心想：天哪，这些人是我一起长大的朋友。所以我开始加他们好友。我打破了我的原则。有个我经常一起玩的叫Chaka的孩子，还有这个叫Alana的女孩和Malcolm Speller。我开始加他们所有人。然后还有另外一个孩子。他叫Eddie。我停住了。”
Should he reach out to Eddie? He'd gone to school with Eddie from since they were first learning to walk, initially, this Jewish day school in the South Side of Chicago.
他该联系Eddie吗？他和Eddie从刚学会走路起就一起上学，最初是在芝加哥南区的一所犹太全日制学校。
We both transferred to this public school in sixth grade. And I remember hearing that his mom told the office lady at the Jewish day school, who told my mom that the reason Eddie transferred schools followed him to the public school, i.e. Ben Austen, meaning me. I was the reason he transferred.
“我们在六年级都转到了这所公立学校。我记得听说他的妈妈告诉犹太学校的办公室女士，而那个女士又告诉了我妈，说Eddie转学的原因是：跟着他转学的阴影，即Ben Austen，也就是我。我是他转学的原因。”
You're the reason he transferred to public school, and then you turned out to go to--
“你是他转学到公立学校的原因，然后你竟然也去了——”
Showed up.
“出现了。”
--the same public school.
“——同一所公立学校。”
Yeah. So I was like, oh, he probably doesn't want to hear from me.
“是的。所以我心想：哦，他可能不想听到我的消息。”
But on the other hand, decades have passed, right? They were adults now. They both had kids. This guy Eddie had actually become a rabbi. And adult Ben didn't want adult Eddie to somehow see that he'd friended everybody else and then not him, and then be hurt by that. So he sends the friend request. Very quickly, he gets a message back.
但从另一方面来看，几十年过去了，对吧？他们现在是成年人了。他们都有了孩子。这个叫Eddie的人竟然成了一名拉比。成年的Ben不想成年的Eddie看到他加了其他人却没加他，从而受到伤害。于是他发出了好友请求。很快，他就收到了回复。
And there seemed to be a 2,000-word essay that he wrote me in response.
“而且他似乎写了一篇2000字的文章作为回复。”
Let me ask you to read a little bit of that.
“让我请你读读那里面的一小部分。”
OK. "Before I broadcast to the world via my 2,100 Facebook friends that you and I are friends, I need to get something off my chest. This may sound petty, but when we were boys at Akiba Schechter, I felt insecure in your presence. From nursery school through fifth grade, I recall feeling verbally and, at times, physically threatened by you.
“好的。‘在我通过我的2100个Facebook好友向全世界广播你我是朋友之前，我需要吐露一些心声。这听起来可能很琐碎，但当我们还是在Akiba Schechter的男孩时，我在你面前感到不安。从幼儿园到五年级，我记得在言语上，有时甚至在身体上，受到你的威胁。’”
I'm not going to go into specific incidents, and I don't think it matters. What matters is how I felt. I'm sad to say it, but when I teach my own children and students in my synagogue about bullying, the image in the deepest recesses of my mind is a memory of feeling threatened by you."
“‘我不想细说具体的事件，我认为那并不重要。重要的是我的感受。我很遗憾地说，当我教自己的孩子和会堂里的学生关于霸凌时，我脑海深处最深刻的形象，就是对你感到威胁的记忆。’”
And then he goes on in his message to you to say, we were kids. I realize it wasn't your fault. You were a kid. And then he says, but even as we got older, I have still carried with me all those years the burden of that experience. And then let me ask you to read how he ends this message to you.
然后他在给你的信息中继续说，我们当时是孩子。我意识到这不是你的错。你当时是个孩子。然后他说，但随着我们长大，在那所有岁月里，我依然背负着那种经历的负担。然后让我请你读读他是如何结束这条信息的。
All right. Ooh. "I need to release myself from the burden that has plagued me for so long. I am sorry for throwing all of this at you over an innocent friend request. I apologize for holding back all these years and not trying harder to bring about healing in our relationship sooner. If you are willing to acknowledge the hurt and the insecurity that I felt in your presence when we were boys more than 30 years ago, then I not only will forgive you, I will be happy to be your friend in all senses of the term. Best regards, Eddie."
“好的。喔。‘我需要从困扰我已久的负担中释放自己。很抱歉因为一个单纯的好友请求就向你倾诉所有这些。我很抱歉这些年来一直隐忍，没有更努力地在我们的关系中寻求治愈。如果你愿意承认当我们还是30多年前的男孩时，我在你面前感受到的伤害和不安，那么我不但会原谅你，我也很高兴能成为你各种意义上的朋友。诚挚的，Eddie。’”
What did you think when you got that?
“收到这个的时候你在想什么？”
Oh, boy. Honestly, I was like, fuck Facebook. But I also thought--
“噢，天哪。老实说，我当时心想：去死吧Facebook。但我也想到——”
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
Wait, you're blaming Facebook for this?
“等等，你在为这事怪Facebook？”
Yeah. I was like, why was I on that site? Why did I participate? It was like, I knew it, I knew it. I mean, to be honest, the biggest thing I felt was-- I just couldn't think of something that I did to him. I don't have any recollection of a single incident of harming him or saying something cruel to him. And at the same time, I'm thinking, that doesn't mean it didn't happen. I'm also thinking, maybe I actually just don't-- I just wasn't aware of it, or I didn't recollect it. So all those things are swirling through my head.
“是的。我心想：我为什么要在那个网站上？我为什么要参与？就像，我早就知道了。老实说，我最大的感受是——我根本想不出我对他做了什么。我不记得任何一次伤害他或对他说了什么刻薄话的事件。同时，我在想，但这并不意味着它没发生。我也在想，也许我只是……我只是没意识到，或者我不记得了。所以所有这些都在我脑子里打转。”
Before this, Ben had never thought of himself as a bully. He says, yeah, as a kid, he was unruly. He spent a lot of time in the principal's office, but generally fun-loving. Nothing like what Eddie was describing. Still, Ben figures, he'll apologize, even though he doesn't remember doing anything. And so then what he ends up writing is this kind of carefully-worded non-apology apology. OK, he writes that he's deeply embarrassed. He's sorry he made Eddie feel this way.
在此之前，Ben从没认为自己是个霸凌者。他说，是的，小时候他很调皮。他花了很多时间在校长办公室，但通常是爱玩。完全不像Eddie描述的那样。尽管如此，Ben想，他还是会道歉，尽管他不记得做了任何事。所以他最终写的是那种措辞谨慎的非道歉式道歉。好吧，他写道他感到非常尴尬。他很抱歉让Eddie有这种感觉。
And then, he can't resist. He goes on to tell this story. It's a memory he had from when they were little kids together. Their teacher had taken the class out to a park across from the school. They're sitting in a circle playing Duck Duck Goose, and this dog runs over, off leash, golden retriever mutt. Maybe it was a puppy, Ben thinks.
然后，他忍不住了。他接着讲了这个故事。这是他从他们还是小孩子时在一起的一个记忆。他们的老师把全班带到了学校对面的一公园。他们坐成一圈玩“捉鸭子”，一只狗跑了过来，没栓绳，金毛杂种犬。Ben想，也许是只小狗。
The most unintimidating dog you could ever see in your life, and I remember looking over and seeing Eddie's face as he saw the dog. And he looked like he had just seen a ghost, just pure terror. He stood up, and I remember shouting at him-- and maybe I'm inventing this memory, but this is how I remember it. I said, Eddie, sit down. The dog isn't interested in you. And he starts to run. And the dog, being a dog, gave chase. And I said to Eddie [LAUGHS] that maybe I was a lot like that dog, you know? Rambunctious, playful, and when things ran, I was the kind of person that would give chase.
“那是你见过最温顺的狗，我记得看着Eddie脸上的表情。他看起来就像刚看到了鬼，纯粹的恐惧。他站了起来，我记得冲他喊——也许是我编造了这个记忆，但我的记忆就是这样。我说：‘Eddie，坐下。狗对你没兴趣。’他开始跑。狗，作为狗，就开始追。我对Eddie说[笑声]，也许我当时就像那条狗，你知道吗？吵闹、爱玩，当东西跑起来，我就是那种会去追的人。”
Were you saying through that story, maybe I did something, but the problem was that you were too scared of me, and I meant you no harm, like that dog? Is that what you're trying to say with this story?
“你是在通过那个故事说，也许我做了什么，但问题是你太怕我了，而我并不想伤害你，就像那条狗？这是你想通过这个故事表达的吗？”
Totally. [CHUCKLES] I was saying, I'm sorry. I don't want you to feel bad. And I'm willing to step up and say the things. But then I also had to tell this damn story, which is like, it's actually not me. It's you. You know? I'm not sure that's fair, but you were scared of things that weren't actually threatening you.
“完全是。[轻笑] 我当时在说：我道歉。我不希望你感觉不好。我愿意站出来承认那些事情。但后来我不得不讲这个该死的故事，这就像是：其实不是我。是你。你知道吗？我不确定这是否公平，但你害怕的是那些其实并没威胁到你的东西。”
Ben ended his message-- "I do understand. I do acknowledge. I am sorry. Sincerely, Ben." So he sends the message. Eddie writes him right back.
Ben结束了他的信息——“我理解。我承认。我很抱歉。诚挚的，Ben。”所以他发出了信息。Eddie立刻写信回复他。
Again, it felt like the ping came back almost the moment I press Send. And he starts-- [HEBREW] "I give thanks to God who has given us life and sustained us and allowed us to reach this moment. Today is a joyful day. I can't adequately express how moved I am by your words. You are a mensch. I am stunned by the accuracy of your recollection of the 53rd Street Park, now the Harold Washington Park. To be honest, I struggled with phobia of dogs well into adulthood."
“感觉就像我按下发送键，ping的一声立刻就回来了。他又开始——[希伯来语]‘我感谢上帝给予我们生命，维持我们，并让我们达到这一时刻。今天是欢乐的一天。我无法充分表达你的话语让我有多么感动。你是个大丈夫（mensch）。你对第53街公园，也就是现在的哈罗德·华盛顿公园的记忆准确性让我震惊。老实说，我成年后一直在对抗狗的恐惧症。’”
And let me just interrupt you there. So then he sort of retells the story, too, but he doesn't seem to understand the point you were trying to make with your story, that maybe he was the one who was a little too scared of things that weren't scary. And then he writes that he feels like he can literally bury the tension between the two of you that went unacknowledged for more than 30 years. Just read his closing lines here.
让我在这打断你。所以他某种程度上也重述了这个故事，但他似乎不理解你试图通过你的故事表达的观点，也许他才是那个对并不吓人的东西太害怕的人。然后他写道，他觉得他可以彻底埋葬你们之间30多年来未被承认的紧张关系。读读他最后的几行。
Yeah. "I am grateful for this new chapter. Needless to say at this point, but still important, I forgive you. I look forward to staying in touch and enjoying a true friendship. Your friend, Eddie."
好的。“我很感激这新篇章。话说到这个地步不用多说，但我还是要说，我原谅你。我期待保持联系，享受真正的友谊。你的朋友，Eddie。”
At this point, do you feel like you might have done something to bully him? Or do you actually not believe you did anything and it's all in his head? Because I think both things are possible, right? You really might have done something real that he could tell you, if you asked him directly. And you realize, oh, yeah, I did that. But it also might be possible he can't come up with any incident. What do you think is the truth?
“到了这一步，你觉得你可能真的霸凌过他吗？还是你根本不相信你做了什么，这全是他脑子里的幻觉？因为我觉得这两种可能性都有，对吧？你真的可能做过什么他能告诉你的具体事件，如果直接问他。你意识到：哦，是的，我确实做了。但也可能他想不出任何具体的事件。你觉得真相是什么？”
Yeah, I actually don't know. I mean, the way you framed that, I have no fucking idea.
“是的，我真的不知道。你是用那种方式定义的，我他妈的根本没头绪。”
This got stuck in Ben's head. What had he done, if anything? Had he been a good kid or a bad kid? Ben decided to find out. It seemed like a good question to ask a rabbi, right? He prepared this report.
这事卡在Ben脑子里了。他到底做了什么，如果有的话？他是个好孩子还是坏孩子？Ben决定找出答案。问拉比这问题好像不错，对吧？他准备了这份报告。
I reach out to Eddie, ask if he's game to revisit the messages we sent back and forth, our memories of each other. Sure, he says, it makes sense to do this in person. He's in Florida, a short drive outside Boca Raton in a subdivision.
我联系Eddie，问他是否愿意重温我们来回发送的信息，我们关于彼此的记忆。他说当然，当面谈有道理。他在佛罗里达州，博卡拉顿外的一个社区。
There's a palm tree right in front of us, sculpted bushes.
前面有一棵棕榈树，修剪过的灌木丛。
There's also a house glowing with Christmas decorations, another displaying a Beware of Dog sign. I know neither can be Eddie's. His is the one in between. Eddie emerges from the front door.
还有一栋房子闪烁着圣诞装饰，另一栋挂着“小心有狗”的牌子。我知道那都不可能是Eddie的。他家在中间那栋。Eddie从前门走了出来。
Eddie.
“Eddie。”
Welcome.
“欢迎。”
Thank you. [CHUCKLES]
“谢谢。[轻笑]”
Great to see you. Thanks for doing this. I hope you got some sun rays today.
“见到你太好了。谢谢你能来。希望你今天晒到了太阳。”
I've seen Eddie only once since we were kids, and I'm struck by how much he looks like the kid I remember, even though he's now about 6 feet with gray in his goatee. He's wearing a yarmulke. He's also got this pouch attached to his belt for his phone. He leads me inside.
自从我们还是孩子以后，我只见过Eddie一次，我被他看起来依然像我记忆中那个孩子的事实惊到了，尽管他现在大约6英尺高，山羊胡子都灰了。他戴着圆顶小帽。他的腰带上还有一个装手机的包。他带我进去。
This is my wife, Ariella.
“这是我妻子，Ariella。”
Hi.
“你好。”
Hi, nice to meet you. Welcome, welcome. I've heard a lot about you.
“你好，幸会。欢迎，欢迎。我对你有所耳闻。”
Hey, good to meet you.
“嘿，幸会。”
His teenage daughter is home. His other two kids are out in the world. He says one is about to get married. He's been a rabbi at different congregations, but he tells me he now works as a chaplain at a hospital. He likes it because he gets to tend to people of all religions. Eddie guides me into the dining room. Laid out on the table, there are all these photographs, nearly every one of them of us.
他十几岁的女儿在家。他的另外两个孩子在外面世界。他说一个快结婚了。他在不同的会堂担任过拉比，但他告诉我他现在在医院担任院牧。他喜欢这份工作，因为他能照顾各种宗教的人。Eddie引导我进入餐厅。桌子上铺着所有的这些照片，几乎每一张都是我们的。
All right. I'm a little embarrassed of seeing all these things.
“好吧。看到这些东西我有点尴尬。”
Yeah, yeah.
“是的，是的。”
It catches me off guard. Eddie's been preparing for this meeting. We went to the same high school, too. Our yearbook is open to my senior picture.
这让我猝不及防。Eddie一直在为这次会面做准备。我们上的同一所高中。我们的毕业纪念册翻在他的毕业照那页。
Yeah, yeah. So that's you.
“是的，是的。所以那是你。”
Aiyaiyai. This--
“哎呀呀。这——”
And that's me.
“那是你。”
I just-- this is--
“我只是——这简直是——”
And your wife is in here.
“你妻子也在里面。”
Yeah, she is.
“是的，她在。”
My wife Danielle also graduated high school with us. Obviously, I kept in better touch with her. Then Eddie points to a faded photo I've never seen before. It's of little kids in a classroom around a table, eating cupcakes. There's Eddie standing, and not far from him, me.
我妻子Danielle也和我们同一届高中。显然，我和她保持了更好的联系。然后Eddie指着一张我从未见过褪色的照片。照片是小孩子在一间教室的桌子旁吃纸杯蛋糕。Eddie站在那儿，离他不远是我。
1977, you and I both turned six. So May was my sixth birthday, and this is my sixth birthday party. So that's me with a crown. And that's you, of course.
“1977年，你我都六岁了。所以五月是我的六岁生日，这是我的六岁生日派对。所以那是戴着皇冠的我。当然，还有你。”
Yeah, front and center.
“是的，就在前面正中间。”
Both of us are smiling as wide as can be. But I know for more than 40 years of Eddie's life, he looked at a photo like this one and was haunted by me. Was he right to feel that way? Have I been wrong all these years about who I am? Eddie tells me about the moment he first heard from me again. He was just down the hall here, in the kitchen, making dinner for his family.
我们俩都笑得极其灿烂。但我知道，在Eddie人生的40多年里，他看着像这样的一张照片，都被我所困扰。他有权那样感觉吗？我这些年来一直对自己是谁的认知是错的吗？Eddie告诉了我他第一次重新听到我的消息时的瞬间。他就在这儿的过道里，在厨房里为家人做晚饭。
I picked up my phone and was getting the table set and whatever, or waiting for dinner to warm up. And I saw a friend request from Ben Austen, and it stopped me cold, in a strange sense that it surprises me, even to this day. Because I mean, I've encountered a lot of people throughout my life. And something was different with you, and that's my memory of you. I felt threatened by you. I felt you were a bully towards me.
“我拿起电话，准备摆桌子什么的，或者等着晚餐热好。我看到了Ben Austen的好友请求，它让我冷彻心扉，那种奇怪的感觉甚至到现在都让我感到惊讶。因为我是说，我一生中遇到过很多人。但你有点不同，那就是我对你的记忆。我感到你威胁。我感到你是个霸凌我的人。”
All right. [SIGHS] This is why I came down here.
“好吧。[叹气] 这就是我来这儿的原因。”
This is a way harder question for me to ask you and one that I've probably avoided. I know I've avoided before. And what did I do? How was I your bully?
“这是我问你一个更难的问题，也是我之前可能避免过的。我知道我之前避免过。但我做了什么？我是怎么霸凌你的？”
Yeah, I'm glad to have the opportunity to discuss it. I didn't want to--
“是的，我很高兴有机会讨论它。我不想——”
Yeah, no.
“是的，没错。”
--burden you about petty stuff. I mean, we're talking about stuff that happened between us when we were six, seven, eight years old. And here we are now, almost on the cusp of being 55 years old. So this is 50 years, almost, in the past. So it seems petty. But do you remember what you called me in those early years?
“——让你背负琐事。我是说，我们谈论的是我们六七岁时发生在我们之间的事情。现在我们几乎快55岁了。所以这是近50年前的事了。所以这看起来很琐事。但你记得你在那些早期岁月里怎么叫我吗？”
Not at all, Eddie. And I'm-- I almost want to run out of the room.
“一点也不，Eddie。我——我几乎想跑出房间。”
OK.
“好的。”
I don't know.
“我不知道。”
All right, so you called me Eddie Spaghetti.
“好吧，你叫我Eddie Spaghetti（意面Eddie）。”
My response right then-- and I feel terrible for saying this-- I want to laugh. I mean, I definitely could see myself saying this. I'm not denying that. But in the absence of any memory of what I did to Eddie, I had imagined-- I don't know-- something so much worse. I came all this way to Florida for a goofy rhyme?
我当时的回应——说这话我感到很糟糕——我想笑。我是说，我绝对能看出我会说这种话。我没否认。但在没有任何记忆我做了什么伤害Eddie的事的情况下，我想象过——我不知道——严重得多的事情。我大老远跑到佛罗里达来是为了一个傻里傻气的韵脚？
For the six-year-old version of me, I was hypersensitive. Every time you called me Eddie Spaghetti, I burst into tears, and the rest of the class would laugh. Mark would laugh, Ari would laugh, and other people would join in calling me Eddie Spaghetti.
“对于六岁的我来说，我太敏感了。每次你叫我Eddie Spaghetti，我就大哭，全班其他孩子都会笑。Mark会笑，Ari会笑，其他人也会跟着叫我Eddie Spaghetti。”
You're pointing at the yearbook pictures here of these kids. Yeah, yeah.
“你指着纪念册上这些孩子的照片。是的，是的。”
And it all seems so silly now.
“现在一切看起来都很傻。”
Well, I'm like--
“嗯，我就像是——”
It's utterly silly. But as a six-year-old kid, I felt like I was the-- I was the one everyone made fun of in class.
“它非常傻。但作为一个六岁的孩子，我觉得我是那个……我是班里大家取笑的对象。”
I do get it. It's about what a hard time Eddie had back then, how much he felt like an outsider, and how I was one of the kids who made it harder. But it's also just so weird, the two of us sitting here, two men in our 50s, and hearing him repeat what I said when I was six or seven. I make a nervous joke about spaghetti being positive. It's noodly flexibility. Plus, it's delicious. Those are the kinds of things I say to people, always have.
“我确实懂。这是关于Eddie当时度过了多么艰难的时光，他觉得自己是个局外人，而我是那些让他情况变得更糟的孩子之一。但这确实很奇怪，我们两个50多岁的男人坐在这里，听到他重复我六七岁时说的话。我开了一个关于意面是积极东西的紧张笑话。它是意面般的灵活性。另外，它很美味。这是我通常对人说的话，一直都是这样。”
I recognize that how you react to Eddie's words, what you feel right now about him or me, probably depends on your relationship to your own past. Maybe you're remembering things being done to you or doing things to someone else. Or maybe you're the type who's forgotten all this sort of stuff, and that's exactly where you want to keep it. Eddie pauses, and I think he's done. That's all he's got. I guess I wasn't such a bad kid after all. But then Eddie looks down at a yellow legal pad. It's covered in handwritten notes. Oof, there's definitely more.
我意识到你对Eddie话语的反应，你现在对他或我有什么感觉，可能取决于你和你自己过去的关系。也许你正记得自己受到的对待或对待某人的方式。或者也许你是那种忘记了所有这类事情的人，而那正是你想保持的地方。Eddie停了下来，我想他讲完了。他只有这些了。我想我终究不是什么坏孩子。但随后Eddie向下看了看黄色的法律记录本。上面密密麻麻写满了笔记。喔，肯定还有更多。
It must have been first or second grade because most of us had those metal lunchboxes, usually with themes from TV shows on them.
“大概是在一年级或二年级，因为我们大多数人都有那种金属饭盒，上面通常印着电视节目的主题。”
And what did you have?
“你有什么？”
My lunchbox was the $6 Million Man with--
“我的饭盒是《无敌金刚》（The $6 Million Man）配上——”
Awesome.
“太棒了。”
--Steve Austin, played by Lee Majors.
“——Steve Austin，由Lee Majors扮演。”
I love it, yeah.
“我喜欢它，是的。”
And so--
“所以——”
This turns out to be a story about a time I did something that seems worse-- physically worse, at least. He says, when we were six, I kicked his ass. I'm not sure why he didn't lead with that. Here's how he remembers it going down.
这原来是一个我做了件看起来更坏——至少身体上更坏的事的故事。他说，我们六岁时，我揍过他。我不确定他为什么没一开始就讲这个。这就是他记忆中发生的事情。
So it's lunchtime. The teacher is telling everybody to get their lunch boxes and line up. And I pull my metal lunchbox off, and someone else's metal lunchbox falls on you, falls on your shoulder. Maybe you had a bruise the next day, but what I do remember is, you then just started whacking me.
“那是午餐时间。老师叫所有人拿上饭盒去排队。我把金属饭盒拉下来，别人的金属饭盒掉在你身上，掉在你肩膀上。也许你第二天有个淤青，但我记得的是，你然后就开始劈头盖脸地揍我。”
Like, I hit you?
“就像，我打了你？”
Yeah, hitting me multiple times. And I really remember seeing your eyes and seeing rage in your eyes.
“是的，打了我好几次。我真的记得看着你的眼睛，看到你眼中的愤怒。”
So I physically--
“所以我在身体上——”
Physically whacking me. And then finally, a teacher came over and separated us, and I don't remember anything else that day. I just remember you hitting me, and I remember the rage in your eyes.
“身体上劈头盖脸地打我。然后终于，老师过来了把我们分开，我不记得那天还发生了什么。我只记得你打了我也记得你眼中的愤怒。”
He says he wasn't seriously injured or anything. We were both just little kids. I don't recall any of this.
他说他没受什么严重的伤或什么的。我们都只是小孩子。我不记得这所有一切。
Well, I'm definitely sorry for that. I don't quite know what to make of it. What does it mean that I did that? I think, Eddie, I probably fought a lot at those times.
“嗯，我确实为此道歉。我不太知道该怎么看这件事。这代表我做了什么？我想，Eddie，那段时间我大概打过很多次架。”
It's terrible I beat Eddie up. This doesn't seem totally out of character for me. I mean, I remember on the playground back then kids throwing a ball in my face. I'd get mad and throw it back in theirs, and then we'd go on playing. What I don't get is why what I did to Eddie that day stood out so much from the other chaos of childhood around us? In the middle school Eddie and I both attended, it wasn't uncommon for one kid to say to another, after school, meaning at 3:30 in the parking lot or on the playground, we're going to fight. It was sometimes said to me.
我揍Eddie真是糟糕。这看起来并不完全不像我的为人。我是说，我记得在当年的操场上，孩子们把球扔在我脸上。我火了就扔回去，然后我们继续玩。我不明白为什么我那天对Eddie做的事，在周围那一团糟的童年里如此突显？在我们上的中学，放学后，即下午3点半在停车场或操场上说“我们打一架”，并不罕见。我有时也会被要求打架。
When we got to high school, I tried to avoid fights as much as possible. The stakes were too high. I saw kids at my school swing bats, golf clubs, once a hatchet. Our junior year, two guys jumped me for a gold chain. My wife says when I showed up at school that week with a broken nose and two black eyes, it was the first time she noticed me, like noticed me as a potential mate. I'm not sure what that says about either of us.
当我们上高中时，我尽量避免打架。赌注太大了。我看到我们学校的孩子挥舞球棒、高尔夫球杆，有一次是一把斧头。高二那年，两个家伙为了抢一条金项链袭击我。我妻子说，当我那周鼻青脸肿去学校时，那是她第一次注意到我，注意到我是一个潜在的伴侣。我不确定这说明我们俩什么。
I remember these moments, but I don't feel plagued by them, not in the way Eddie was by me. But I realize, in saying all that, part of me is defending myself, little kid Ben. I'm trying to prove I wasn't a bully. Later, I even talk with an elementary school principal in Chicago to see whether my actions back then check their four boxes of bullying. I did check at least two. Eddie has one more memory on his notepad that he wants me to hear.
我记得这些时刻，但我没感到受折磨，不像Eddie那样被我折磨。但我意识到，在说这一切时，部分我在捍卫自己，小孩Ben。我正试着证明我不是霸凌者。后来，我甚至和芝加哥的一位小学校长谈过，看看我当年的行为是否符合霸凌的四个标准。我确实符合至少两项。Eddie的笔记本上还有一个他想让我听的记忆。
As I recall, we're at the 53rd Street Park. Our teacher took us out on a nice day. We're sitting, playing Duck Duck Goose. And--
“我记得，我们在第53街公园。老师把我们带出去玩了一天。我们坐着玩‘捉鸭子’。然后——”
He repeats the same story I shared with him in our Facebook exchange. It starts just as I remember, but with a different conclusion. It's that story of how when we were seven or eight, and our class went to the park, a dog was off leash.
他重复了我俩在Facebook交换中分享的同一个故事。它开始就像我记得的那样，但结局不同。那就是我们七八岁时，全班去公园，一条狗没栓绳的故事。
I had a serious phobia, and I just hightailed it. And I ran screaming. I don't know if it was that time, but I know there were other times that I ran across Hyde Park Boulevard, which is a busy street with buses and cars and trucks, back to the safe side, where the school building was. And I remember being laughed at by you and other students in the class. I'm not saying you're the only one, but I perceived you as the ringleader.
“我有严重的恐惧症，我直接跑了。我尖叫着跑开了。我不知道是不是那次，但我知道还有其他几次我跑过海德公园大道，那是一条有很多公交车、汽车和卡车的繁忙街道，回到了安全的一侧，就是学校建筑所在的地方。我记得被你和班里的其他学生嘲笑。我不是说你是唯一一个，但我认为你是带头人。”
Man. I mean, in the story I told, it was the opposite of laughing.
“天哪。我是说，在我讲的故事里，完全不是嘲笑。”
Yeah.
“是的。”
Like, I was trying to protect you.
“比如，我当时在试图保护你。”
Of course.
“当然。”
That's the part we remember so differently. Maybe I've held on to my version because in it, I've cast myself as the good guy. I see his terror, and I'm the one calling out to him, telling him not to run. Eddie describes another boy who teased him that day about how fast Eddie ran from the dog. He could be a track star if there was always a dog behind him. Eddie blamed me for that one, too. That's just how he saw me back then.
“这就是我们记忆完全不同的地方。也许我坚持我的版本是因为在里面，我把自己塑造为好人。我看到他的恐惧，而我是那个冲他喊话，告诉他别跑的人。Eddie描述了那天另一个嘲笑他的男孩，关于Eddie跑得有多快，如果后面总有条狗，他能成田径明星。Eddie也把那归咎于我。那时候他就是那样看我。”
My memory over the arc of our young childhood was being teased by you. And at some point, that became layered on my dog phobia. And so, in a way, you became the dog.
“我年幼时记忆的弧线就是被你取笑。在某个点，那与我的恐惧症交织在一起。所以，在某种程度上，你变成了那条狗。”
[CHUCKLES] And I mean--
[轻笑] “我是说——”
I became the dog? For Eddie, I turned into this major figure in his life. I became this villain. Eddie tells me that when he changed schools, I wasn't the only reason, but I was part of it. And he tells me how, decades later, he saw a photo. It was from our 20th high school reunion. He spotted me in the background and was relieved he didn't go. Then-- classic me-- I sent him that note which was way more clever than honest. He opened it at a cemetery after presiding over a funeral. He tells me it was like a spell was broken. It set him free.
“我变成了那条狗？对Eddie来说，我变成他生命中的重要人物。我变成了恶棍。”Eddie告诉我，当他转学时，我不是唯一原因，但我是原因之一。他告诉我，几十年后，他看到了一张照片。那是我们高中毕业20周年聚会的。他在背景里发现了我也松了口气没去。然后——典型的我——我发给他那张既巧妙又不诚实的字条。他在主持一场葬礼后在墓地打开了它。他告诉我，那就像咒语被破除了。它让他获得了自由。
I think I just wept at that moment. I was just so grateful to hear or to read that you had accepted what I wrote with such incredible grace. And I just felt blessed. It was big. It was a momentous time in my life. I mean, it's a time that there's a before and there's an after.
“我想我在那一刻只是泪流满面。听到或读到你以这种难以置信的优雅接受了我写的那些东西，我非常感激。我感觉自己被祝福了。这很宏大。这是我生命中一个重要的时刻。我是说，这是一个有前有后的时刻。”
Eddie, wow, that's powerful and complicated.
“Eddie，哇，这很强大也很复杂。”
Yeah, complicated. I decide to tell Eddie the truth, how in that message, the one that broke the spell, I had said sorry, but wasn't sure I had done anything wrong. My apology wasn't really an apology. Did he understand that when he got it?
“是的，很复杂。”我决定告诉Eddie真相，在那个破除咒语的信息里，那个我说了对不起，但又不确定我做错什么的信息里。我的道歉其实算不上道歉。他收到时理解这一点吗？
I think I did, or at least, in retrospect, I did. I remember sharing it with other people, and they said, did he really apologize? And my sense is that perhaps not fully, but it was enough. It was what I needed at that moment. And perhaps I chose to layer more apology on it than you were actually saying at the time. But you finished your note saying, I acknowledge, and I'm sorry. And that's what I needed at that moment. And that's what I embraced.
“我想我理解了，或者至少，回想起来，我理解了。我记得和别人分享过，他们说：‘他真的道歉了吗？’我的感觉是，也许不够充分，但那足够了。那是当时我所需要的。也许我选择了在上面叠加比你当时说的更多的歉意。但你在字条最后写道：我承认，我很抱歉。那就是我当时所需要的。那就是我所拥抱的。”
It's not just that Eddie and I see our memories of each other differently. I realize we also have a different way of seeing the world. Eddie, he's a man of faith. If it's enough, it's enough. Not me. I can't help it. I need to set the record straight.
不只是Eddie和我以不同的方式看待我们关于彼此的记忆。我意识到我们看待世界的方式也不同。Eddie，他是信仰坚定的人。如果足够，那就足够了。我可不行。我忍不住。我需要把记录整理清楚。
I'm embarrassed about the things I did and that I hurt you. But I'm also thinking that a lot of it is just, it's about being kids.
“我很尴尬我做过的事情，我也伤害了你。但我也在想，很多只是，只是作为孩子。”
Yeah.
“是的。”
And I don't think I was a bully in that sense. And I wonder if you think I am.
“我不觉得我那是霸凌。我好奇你是否觉得我是。”
No, absolutely.
“不，绝对不是。”
I don't mean right now. I mean, when you think back on those moments.
“我不是指现在。我是指，当你回想那些时刻。”
How can I look at this picture of six-year-old Ben smiling and--
“我怎么能看着这张六岁Ben灿烂微笑的照片然后——”
But come on. But you looked at that picture for years and saw the dog.
“但拜托。你多年来看着那张照片，看到的却是那条狗。”
Yes. Yes. But this little six-year-old Ben, smiling, grinning. It's sweetest. I mean, look, you can pinch the cheeks practically. And--
“是的。是的。但这小小的六岁Ben，微笑着，咧着嘴。太甜了。我是说，看，脸颊都快能掐出来了。而且——”
But that feels like a revisionist history of how you saw that picture before--
“但这感觉像是在修改之前你如何看待那张照片的历史——”
But--
“但——”
--that loomed in your imagination. [LAUGHS]
“——这在你想象中徘徊。”[笑声]
But I am revising it now, but we as adults have a right to change the narrative.
“但我现在正在修改它，但我们作为成年人有权改变叙事。”
Eddie, I feel like your version of me today and over time is both, I'm way worse than I am, and I'm better than I am. There's a little bit of way of when you're saying you're seeing my true self-- I guess what I'm saying is, you're also seeing these two extremes and I'm some-- I'm not really either of those.
“Eddie，我觉得你今天和随时间推移对我版本的印象，既——我比我实际上糟得多，我又比我实际上好得多。当你说是看到我的真实自我时有一点这种方式——我想说的是，你同时也看到了这两个极端，我是一些——我真的都不是那些。”
As he's pointing at this photo of me, it's like everything has flipped. I'm no longer even a bully when I was a kid. And as an adult, he's talking about me like this great liberator. He even compares me at one point to a famous rabbi who marched with Martin Luther King.
当他指着这张我的照片时，感觉一切都翻转了。我甚至不再是一个小孩子时的霸凌者。作为成年人，他谈论我就像谈论这个伟大的解放者。他甚至在某一点上把我比作一位与马丁·路德·金一起游行的著名拉比。
In some ways, what I'm hearing is, I've sort of liberated you from this stuff, which just also feels-- yeah, I don't know. That doesn't feel exactly me either. I mean, I try to do-- I want to do good.
“在某种程度上，我听到的是，我某种程度上把你从这些东西中解放了出来，这也感觉——是的，我不知道。那也不完全是我。我是说，我努力去——我想做善事。”
OK, yeah. Yeah, well, look, there's people come to me and say that time you spent with me in the hospital or that sermon you gave, it changed my life. And did I really do anything? I did what I do every day. Every day, I visit people in the hospital. Every day, I study some piece of scripture or Jewish wisdom and try to make some meaning out of it for a congregation. And sometimes it lands, and sometimes it doesn't. And with you, you did something good. And I'm holding it up as good. How does that sound?
“好的，是的。是的，好吧，听着，有人来找我，说你在医院花的时间和我做的布道，它改变了我的生活。我真的做了什么吗？我做了我每天做的事。每一天，我都探望医院里的人。每一天，我都研究经文或犹太智慧，试着为会堂做出意义。有时它有效，有时无效。而对你来说，你做了好事。我把它视为善。这听起来怎么样？”
It sounds like Eddie's a pretty good rabbi, and that he got what he needed from me. See? I'm not such a bad guy. But I got something out of this, too. It's clear Eddie and I didn't know each other well as kids, and certainly not as adults either.
听起来Eddie是个相当不错的拉比，他从我身上得到了他所需要的。你看？我不是什么坏人。但我也从中得到了一些东西。很明显Eddie和我也没在孩子时真正了解彼此，成年的话当然也没有。
But here I am in Florida, in his subdivision, in his home. I can see the books on his shelves. His kids' artwork is on the walls. He's got a tree out back in his yard. It grows starfruit. Eddie's cut up slices for us to snack on. And we've managed on this night to talk for hours. I do feel responsible for my past actions, even the ones from way back that I can't remember. As far as what to do about that, we now know each other, at least better. That feels real. Maybe at this point in our lives, it's about the best we can do. Amen.
但就在这儿，在佛罗里达，在他社区，在他家里。我能看到他书架上的书。他孩子的艺术作品在墙上。他后院里有棵树。长着杨桃。Eddie切了片让我们当零食吃。而我们在这个晚上设法谈了几个小时。我确实对过去的行动负责，即使是那些遥远得我记不得的行为。至于对此该做什么，我们现在了解彼此了，至少好了一些。那感觉很真实。也许在我们生命的这个节点，这已经是我们能做到的最好的了。阿门。
Ben Austen is a writer in Chicago. His most recent book is Correction, about the parole system.
Ben Austen是芝加哥的一名作家。他最新的书是《Correction》，关于假释系统。
["GETTING TO KNOW YOU" BY NANCY WILSON]
["Getting to Know You", Nancy Wilson演唱]
Today's show was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld and Tobin Low. The people who put together the show include Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, and Christopher Swetala. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由Aviva DeKornfeld和Tobin Low制作。组建节目的成员包括Phia Bennin, Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Cassie Howley, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Robin Reid, Nadia Reiman, Anthony Roman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, 和 Christopher Swetala。我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks to Adam Ross at the Sewanee Review, Shin Yu Pai, Lauren Hirs, Sara Veldhuizen Stealy, Cara Dietz, Jodi Krumel, and Peter Kornbluh. Peter Lang-Stanton, who you heard at the beginning of the show talking about his parents being in the CIA, made a radio story years ago about his dad's involvement in covert operations in Laos during the Vietnam War. We link to it from our website, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢Sewanee Review的Adam Ross, Shin Yu Pai, Lauren Hirs, Sara Veldhuizen Stealy, Cara Dietz, Jodi Krumel, 和 Peter Kornbluh。Peter Lang-Stanton，你们在节目开头听到的谈论他父母在中情局工作的人，几年前做过一个关于他父亲在越南战争期间参与老挝秘密行动的广播故事。我们从我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org 链接到它。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. If you'd like to get bonus episodes, if you'd like to listen to all of our regular episodes without the ads, and most importantly, if you would like to help us keep making the show, please consider becoming a This American Life partner. There are more than 20 bonus episodes waiting for you right now, including a brand new one where one of the people who adds music underneath our stories here on the show explains the sometimes very puzzling situations that she has gotten in with certain stories and her attempts to figure out what music to use.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换机构 PRX 交付给公共广播电台。如果您想获得额外剧集，如果您想在没有广告的情况下收听我们所有的常规剧集，最重要的是，如果您想帮助我们继续制作节目，请考虑成为《美国生活》的合作伙伴。现在有超过20个额外剧集等着你，包括一个全新的，其中一位在我们故事下添加背景音乐的成员解释了她在某些故事中遇到的有时非常令人困惑的情况，以及她试图弄清楚使用什么音乐的尝试。
Join at thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He told me this week he's switching from Netflix to HBO Max for one reason--
在 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners 加入。该链接也在节目注释中。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他本周告诉我他正在从Netflix转到HBO Max，原因只有一个——
They didn't really have friends.
“他们没什么真正的好友。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回《美国生活》的更多故事。
["GETTING TO KNOW YOU" BY BILL PERKINS & NANCY WILSON]
["Getting to Know You", Bill Perkins & Nancy Wilson演唱]